the national median rent is now the
lowest it's been since February of 2022
but what does that mean for us in Las
Vegas so 8 news now anchor Kirsten Joyce
spoke to the experts to get some answers
the national median rent is now 1937
this number is a combination of all
prices for Studios one two and three
bedroom apartments for contacts rental
prices peaked in August of 2022 at an
average of two thousand fifty three
dollars what's contributed to
um the the drop in in rent prices has
been uh both a a large influx of new
Supply
more inventory has come online uh while
at the same time uh that we've seen a
huge decrease in demand rent.com's
researcher John Leckie adds the cooling
in the National housing market over the
past eight months creeps into the rental
market bringing those prices down
nationally rent prices are down a little
over five and a half percent I want to
look at uh Nevada and Las Vegas it's a
similar story you know both the state
and the city uh are are down year over
year Nevada's down a little over four
percent uh city of Los Vegas is is down
a little over two and a half percent and
they're both relatively flat uh on a
month-to-month basis those price drops
are coming to an end says lucky however
here in Las Vegas he says we are already
starting to see the housing market
rebound and the rental market will
follow typically rent decreases in the
fall and winter and starts to creep back
up in spring and summer and he expects
this year we'll see a return to the
seasonal Trends once prices are going to
go back up in the summertime
um as as you know we get some more of
that demand from you know new renters
coming out of school or uh you know
people deciding to move when the
weather's a little bit warmer